hello man establish a critic I
remembered so you don't have to well
I've gotten emails and emails and emails
and emails of people requesting me to do
this one certain movie well today I'm
finally gonna give it this is it one of
the big ones one of the worst ones ever
I am going to review the room that's
right
the college film that I made growing up
I surprise you guys want me to review
this so bad I mean it's not very long
and I made a years ago but ever since I
showed in my flashback section you've
all requested me to do it so let's not
waste any time let's dive right into
crap who are you I'm you from the future
well what are you doing here am i doing
here what are we doing here
this isn't the movie they wanted to
review credit that's one what was that
they say it's one of the worst movies of
all time oh really
oh it's tempting what was it me all the
way in 2003 the banks have two main
cutoff date that's barely in this town
I know that's why I come to take you
shut off your top the target will be
nostalgic oh oh I want to renew my
college movie is gonna be funny
no it wasn't yes it was what were you
gonna use another chunk Noah's joke
again maybe come on no time
[Music]
Wow so what year is this the future are
all right but why am i downstairs in the
basement oh it's the only place we can
hide to stay away from the seahorses oh
okay
what Oh
seahorses rule the earth now complete
domination surprise nobody saw it coming
really
[Music]
well I'll just deal with it as it comes
so let's not waste same time let's dive
right into the room
[Music]
okay so after we get our logo that looks
like it should be before a turbo
graphics 16 game we cut to our opening
credits we get some fairly decent shots
of San Francisco as we see the star of
our movie is Tommy Wiseau who I guess
was also things I could do producer and
the writer and the producer again G even
the director of this film really liked
Tommy with soap or I'm just gonna go out
on a limb here and say yeah just as I
thought
looks like we have a personal story of
your people be very afraid I babe I have
something for you come on come on
where's the real performance the bank
saves money and they're using me and I'm
the fool no seriously guys come on
where's the real actor you're part of my
lights you are everything I could not go
on without you Lisa
No what about Elizabeth huh no let me
guess that's Tommy Wiseau oh no that's
the kind of acting the only talked about
in fairy tales the kind of acting that
they said could never exist
don't do it critic obscurest lupa I've
reviewed this movie already there's no
need for you to sacrifice your sanity as
well I must lupa true it'll be hard to
sit through this anus of a performance
but I must do it for my fans Oh what do
we do oh so yeah this is our main
character everybody you know that creepy
guy who always looks at you funny on the
subway yeah he made a movie apparently
and in that movie he plays Johnny the
fiancee of a pretty young woman named
Lisa oh hey guys oh hi there
and this is Danny we don't know that
much about him but after a few scenes
you'll wish to stay that way
nice to see you Danny I'm going to take
your nap can I go upstairs too haha
Danny I think I'm gonna join it so a kid
comes over and they go upstairs to have
sex well it's kind of rude what's the
kids supposed to do
I mean is he supposed to just go
upstairs and join them
[Laughter]
Danny do you have something else to do I
just like to watch you guys Danny two's
great with freezer crowd I get it you
guys want to be alone that's the idea
9 I have homework to do anyway I love
birds bye Danny
so was that a charming scene or should
we be emotionally disturbed oh well who
cares we have a gratuitous sex scene to
shoot which apparently they waited until
night to do considering they started
during the day as soon as they start
taking their clothes off it's at night
what did they just pillow fight the
whole time why I feel this way about you
but hey if you think it took a while for
them to start making out see how long it
takes for them to actually start having
sex I mean it they kiss play with their
clothes she puts her hair down just so
she can put it back up again it
practically takes forever yes
and once you know it even the sex is
really off I mean look at this angle
here really look at is he fucking your
belly button cuz it looks like he's
fucking her belly button dude I don't
know how many times you've had sex but
it's not that tight so I'm guessing five
days later they finally get sex over
with or whatever the hell you call that
so Johnny gives up for a minute and
watches acting you gotta show me his ass
actually this whole scene plays like a
sex tape going wrong in fact I bet
that's what happened I thought that's
exactly what happened tell me which so
was filming himself in this girlfriend
having sex when somebody came across the
tape they confronted him about it and he
said oh no no it's not sex tape is a
independent movie I'm making yeah that's
it
independent movie and I'm in it and so
is my girlfriend honey I had to think of
something we just have to make movie now
but neither of us can act we make movie
now so Lisa's mother comes over as she
feels something is wrong what's wrong
tell me I don't love him anymore why
don't you love him anymore tell me so
boring okay if making love to your navel
is boring I don't wanna know what
exciting is he supports you he provides
for you and darling you can't support
yourself and his position is very secure
yes your job that will never explain
I'll see you do makes much less than his
job which will never explain I'll see
him do so we see Lisa called Johnny's
best friend mark as she invites him over
for a quote-unquote talk
thank you it's hot I mean the candles
music the sexy dress I mean what's going
on here mrs. Robinson you're trying to
seduce you I like you very much
lover boy what are you doing this floor
dude I thought we were gonna talk don't
you like me
Johnny's my best friend forget about
Johnny yeah I'm leaving then
please don't leave please don't leave
dude I like debt okay
I liked Dex I didn't know you wanted
that spilled out for you but ultimately
he does give in as mark and Lisa partake
in spiral stair sex interesting location
but more important things are going on
like Johnny buying his girlfriend some
flowers yeah can I have a dozen red
roses please oh hi Johnny I didn't know
what you what here you go
that's me huh how much is it it'll be
$18 go keep the change
bye doggy you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye bye bye okay hold on
what just happened I mean I know he's
just buying her some flowers but I think
they're reading the script backwards or
something in fact let's analyze this
scene I mean I know I'm the picking but
this whole 20 seconds really fascinates
me yeah can I have a dozen red roses
please oh hi Johnny I didn't know it was
you you didn't know it was him he didn't
recognize the five foot girlie haired
French zombie until he took off his
sunglasses here you go that's me
why did he say that she didn't give him
any reason to say that is that just as
random catchphrase of the day how much
is it it'll be $18 go keep the change
hi doggie you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye and what was up with
the rushed pace of that last couple
seconds did they only have enough money
to rent the store for like two minutes
so they had to shoot it really fast
hello I would like to buy a dozen roses
hey jackass I'm closing the store in 30
seconds here's the money keep the change
hello doggy bye hey Danny how are you
doing I'm fine
you look beautiful today can I kiss you
you are such a little brat just kidding
I love you and Johnny you know this
movie's awkward enough kid it doesn't
need your help
hi babe
is that for you did you get your
promotion
you didn't get it did you what part of
nad did you not understand but betrayed
me but didn't keep their promise they
tricked me and I don't care anymore
Jesus you know jean-claude van damme
could be an English teacher compared to
this guy you need a drink
so she makes him a drink of vodka and
wine as they get ready for another night
of slow awkward sex let's roleplay you
be Sonya Blade and I'll be a terrible
actor don't do it Critic there's still
time Linkara
you don't want to sit through the room
it sucked out your mind and replaces it
with stupid
dammit Linkara I made a promise to get
through this film and by god I'm gonna
take it you mad critic man be gone okay
so after Johnny and Lisa take another
week to have sex Lisa's mother trusts by
again to give more advice everything
goes wrong at once nobody wants to help
me and I'm dying you're not dying mom I
got the results of the tests back I
definitely have breast cancer
nights well gee you're taking it pretty
well look don't worry about it
everything will be fine she's taking it
despicably well - I'm so glad this
wasn't any serious bad news you know
like maybe Lisa's getting bored or
something well at least you have a good
man you're wrong he didn't get his
promotion and he got drunk last night
and he hit me
Johnny doesn't drink she just admitted
that he hits her and the mothers like
Johnny doesn't drink I know he hits you
like a football players wife but he
doesn't drink meanwhile two friends of
Lisa come spontaneously out of nowhere
to sneak into her apartment and have sex
did you know chocolate is the symbol of
love did you also know that when it
rains
o people get wet hello
what are these characters doing here I
don't know they serve no purpose to the
story and bring the film to yet another
complete halt so I guess you'll have to
ask the English challenge director
meanwhile Deni is confronted with some
bad news you have my money right yeah
it's coming it'll be R in a few minutes
the movie was financed
where is my money you don't have
anything you where's my money daddy it's
down there somewhere let me take another
look but luckily John eanes friends are
there to save the day what did that man
want from you nothing oh that was not
nothing
tell me everything if you have no idea
what kind of trouble you're in here do
you yeah kid how dare you have a man man
point a gun at you that's really
inconsiderate I owe him some money what
kind of money I bought some drugs off of
him things got mixed up I didn't mean
for this to happen but Deni don't you
know
a man holds a gun on you you almost got
killed you expect me to forget that
right you're not my fucking mother
you listen somebody had better do
something around here granny will push
the cap in your ass
are you okay Danny what's okay he's
taking drugs let's go home you know that
Johnny's like your father and we're your
friends we're gonna help you
let's go home hey Johnny what was the
point of that Steve never question me or
I cut you I ask you I just saw you what
are you talking about
so yeah Lisa invites mark over again as
Johnny finally heard the lie that Lisa
told about him I did not hit her it's
not true it's bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark I did not hit her
it's not true don't play it again I
think the evidence is very clear that is
the worst piece of acting that has ever
been put on film I mean my god not one
inflection was right not one word was
said correctly not one breath of air
made me believe anything that he was
saying there are middle school plays
that put on better performances than
that couple of seconds that was like the
Nirvana of bad acting the Holy Grail all
hail to you your lameness I did not hit
her I did not oh hi mark
boy gone
you think girls like that she'd like
guys do what makes you say that
I'm just thinking I just know a girl she
had a dozen guys one of them found out
about it beat her up so bad she ended up
in a hospital in Guerrero Street that's
not funny you sick fuck haha what a
story mark yeah you can say that again
I think he just did that Lang was
horribly dumped what a story mark yeah
you can say that again
oh can I thank you hey Jonny oh hi Danny
what's wrong with mark he's cranky today
stop laughing at things that aren't
funny it goddamn weirdo and why isn't
her wind blowing in their hair
it's about Lisa go on she looks great in
a red dress I think I'm in love with her
go on go on but you mean more I feel
like I want to kiss her and tell her
that I love her don't worry about that
Lisa loves you too as a person as a
human being
Wow people take shockingly bad news
really well in this movie did everybody
just take a xanax cocktail in this story
you can love someone deep inside your
heart and there is nothing wrong with it
if a lot of people love each other the
world would be a better place to live
you can read about it in my new book the
Tao of Johnny it's real good huh you
have any problems talk to me and I will
help you awesome thanks Johnny let's go
eat huh oh gee can we eat huh I've never
had table before is there a restaurant
somewhere around here so Johnny comes
home as Lisa's friend Michelle is just
leaving I can't talk right now
why Lisa well you said please talk to me
please
you are lying I never hit you
you got Tammy partly shop oh my god why
are you so hysterical do you understand
life do you you know what I got it you
know what this guy is he's the bizarro
Fabio same hokey acting same undefinable
accent except where Fabio was muscular
and good luck
this guy is good never show that again
so the guys meet up and throw a football
in the alley because that's what guys do
I guess as mark lightly taps one of his
friends and he falls over like a clumsy
ox what's the point of the sequence
nothing you can pretty much make trading
cards out of how many pointless
sequences there are in this movie let's
go home Danny boy he really wants to get
that kid home a lot doesn't he
I'm not gonna question anything but I am
gonna play this music
[Music]
so Lisa's mother comes over again to
have yet another tedious dialogue I
expected your husband to be a little
more generous he's not my husband I know
but Johnny is part of our family
mom I don't love Johnny anymore I don't
even like him didn't we have this
conversation like five other times she's
like you should like Johnny I don't
you're a slut yes what else is there to
talk about
so Johnny and Mark sit down and have a
talk with their other good friend Peter
hey are you running a beta breakers this
year I am sure no I'm not doing it this
year ha ha ha chicken feet are you just
a little chicken Gigi this has been
another moment no critic don't do it
spoonie don't throw your life away it's
not worth it ok look I'm getting through
this movie in that final no critic
nobody should be forced to watch
Highlander - I'll endure - I'm never
viewing Highlander - OH
for a minute there I thought you'd gone
totally insane that's a relief
so tell me what movie are you reviewing
well I'm reviewing the room thanks for
that so all the guys get dressed up in
their tuxedos as my guest they're
getting ready to go to the wedding oh
wait no they're going out to throw the
football around again ok well then are
they going to the wedding
no they just take them off and go on
with their daily lives
do they always wear it touches when they
play football is that just an everyday
occurrence for them what's that you're
going to play football oh great I'll go
put out my finest tux oh wait no no no
it getting married tomorrow so uh I got
I read out my Jersey we got a new client
and the bank will make a lot of money
what client I cannot tell you it's
confidential oh come on why not
no I can anyway how is your sex life I
can't talk about it
why not why not how about just prodded
the fuck out of nowhere you weird alien
ma'am and yes speaking of awkward Lee
sent bytes mark over for another night
of frills what's going on here oh my god
do you need landing lights to the bed
she wants to sleep with you that's the
thing she does every other stinking time
you're over you fucking idiot yeah yeah
yeah and circuit hoon is sexy so then we
cut - holy shit do these guys do
anything else other than play football
this is unbelievable they're not even
playing football they're just throwing
it back and forth do they even know the
rules of football why don't you get a
new hobby you know like mark he's made a
wonderful hobby out of screwing his best
friend's fiancee and yet acting totally
surprised every time he does it boy this
movie isn't nearly repetitive enough
though why don't we have yet another
talk with Lisa's mother as they discuss
the same thing they discussed in the
last three conversations I'm fixing the
apartment for Johnny's birthday but I'm
really not into it oh why not wait wait
wait I'm keen to guess mmm
I know love with mark not Johnny I'm in
love with Mark not Johnny it's not right
Lisa it's not right least yeah bad so
after Johnny returns from his Grimer
Wormtongue audition we see a surprise
party being thrown for his birthday
yeah later yes okay enough of that scene
[Music]
and now back to that seat what was that
the screen saver while the movie loads
[Music]
hey everybody let's go outside for some
fresh air
wait I have something I want to show you
oh really
hey what's going on here that's right
just make out during your own fiancees
birthday party what in all probability
could go wrong what's going on here oh
yeah there's tons of people around and
you can get caught at any minute you
understand what you're doing you're
going to destroy Johnny he's very
sensitive that's right you listen to me
whoever I am so the night goes on mark
and Johnny start to get on each other's
nerves you really don't know do you
maybe I know more than you think I do
mark shit all right what do you want
from me huh all right okay folks
everything is fine five days over fun
I'm sorry Laura well good it looks like
that's over with
she doesn't want to talk to you since
when do you give me orders it's Lisa
changed your mind about you wake up man
what planner you want that's the first
legitimate question I've heard this book
I think you should leave right now mark
worry about it man
don't touch me motherfucker get out
pshh rappy you're not good you just
chicken chip chip chip chip chip
nobody poorly imitates my favorite farm
animal everybody betrayed me I fed up
with his world
oh sheesh you know it's like Christopher
Walken if they sucked out all like
ability ouch
so Johnny locks himself in the bathroom
and refuses to come out you can come out
now Johnny in a few minutes bitch
say you know what this seems like a
perfect time to do hey Mark I need to
talk to you
Oh God bar you atheria don't worry about
Johnny he's just being a big baby I'm
standing right here mom you know I love
you very much
bury me up by my side so Johnny finally
throws the bitch out as he throws the
most over-the-top and yet somehow
nonchalant temper tantrum
yeah yeah I'm angry I guess roar roar
I'm really mean and frustrated huh these
is what angry people do right ah finally
Johnny can take it no more
he puts this God forsaken performance to
a stop
wake up Johnny come on wake up I don't
think you really wake up from a bullet
in the mouth is he dead is he well yes
yes he is young lady he has passed on
this person is no more
he has ceased to be he's expired and
gone to meet his maker he's a stiff
bereft of life he rests in peace if he
didn't shoot himself he'd be pushing up
daisies his metabolic processes are now
history he's off the twig he's kicked
the bucket he shuffled off the mortal
coil one doesn't run and join the
frigging choir invisible this is an ax
person
well better replace it then goodnight
sweet pretty lights of asshole sing thee
to thy rest
I've lost him but I still have you right
right wow that's a clumsy rebound you
don't have me mark we're free to be
together
I love come on we'll have sex on his
corpse only tons of fun cavities Ted
[Music]
for never has there been a tale of more
blur than this dumbass bitch and her
tummy was her and that's the room cry
city Christ Christ Christ this movie is
a miracle I've never seen a performance
so consistently bad or writing so
hypnotizing relate but to be honest I
know you're gonna think I'm crazy it's
really worth checking out it truly is
one of those movies you have to see to
believe
nobody could willingly make a movie this
interestingly bend it had to be the
warmed mindset of some weirdo who's
International origins remain a mystery
so if you're really up for some
absolutely horrible yet surprisingly
entertaining shit this movie is for you
and that's my review I hope you enjoyed
it everything we've got to go that our
other sauce
why what's go are you watching the moon
no you know that movie is out
[Music]
well I gotta admit after going through
all that it sure is nice to be back in
my old room hey I'll call my walls a bit
of a different color oh my god I
travelled back and forth so much that
must have altered the present well
whether the machines have taken over
what a few minutes I switch places
what if all cops are judge jury and
executioner what if Christopher's aside
by radio announcer an attack actually
nothing's different your walls just a
bit of a different colour really that's
it no they're huge mind boggling alter
agents at all look just a different wall
know that you have a tail now well I'll
take a locating used to welcome to my
new location I hope you enjoy it and as
always I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember
you
you are taming poor Lisa